herzlich willkommen wir starten wir
wieder ganz klassisch mit dem besten tik
tok der woche also wer mir noch nicht
bei tik tok laser luca gefolgt ist soll
sich auch auf instagram wir werden die
wir sprachen lernen dadurch diesen bogen
strom da war ich einfach nur danke für
die weisheit des tages
[Musik]
meine lieben freunde damit herzlich
willkommen zu einer neuen episode tik
tok tuesday das format wo qualität ganz
groß geschrieben wird
[Musik]
was
das wissen tik tok von einem lehrer der
von seinen studenten also von seinen
schülern aus einer video-konferenz
geklickt wurde
meine frau kate sind jetzt ein neues
scheibenwischer gelegen und jetzt wieder
schluss funktioniert die kann er sich
schon mal kaputt
[Musik]
warum habe ich so viel schadenfreude in
meinem körper
[Musik]
daher immer noch besser als hilfe
schauspieler
ja die quarantäne macht uns alle
verrückt wie ihr wahrscheinlich auch
meiner heutigen instagram story gesehen
habt es sind das ja das passiert mir
nicht der eintritt okay ich hab mich
jetzt vorbereitet eigentlich kann man
das jetzt nicht noch mal passiert von
daher was machst du kannst du nicht
einfach das licht erscheint nicht sehen
nichts mehr hundertprozentig die
wahrheit freunde egal ob ich bin meinem
vater meiner mutter oder mit
irgendwelchen anderen leuten mit denen
ich nicht verwandt war gefahren bin
immer wenn man hinten gesessen
das licht angemacht
man kann mich mit so einem schwachsinn
zu machen bringen haben wir kein
bisschen qualitäts content heute
[Musik]
[Applaus]
was
das ist ja das sieht ja unsere satisfied
aus
ich weiß
ja das was soll ich jetzt sagen
manni welche frucht eine farbe
gelb
[Musik]
ich weiß ich sagt dass in jedem
verdammten video weise soll auch wieder
die wahrheit
[Musik]
das ist mein leben in der natur
deutsch schon eine schöne sprache die
leute schlafen kam morgen wieder home
office ist der bus ist der größte
dinosaurier aus der familie der
vogelbeckensaurier nur die echten tik
tok tuesday fans werden das jetzt
verstehen so nahmen sie an der tanke
sachen dann platzt jetzt nicht zeit als
chef
[Musik]
die nur aus münchen deutschland
sie das so schön aus wenn man einfach
nur die smarties und dann wasser in die
mitte wenn wir das hier unter 33 auch
mal ein paar gedanken was oma ist
kräuter gestern klar warum haben wir
eigentlich in jeder folge dieser oma
mit ihrem enkelkind dabei bin hat er
geht in einen supermarkt einkaufen was
glaubst du wohl ein
es sind keine eier und keine schokohasen
es wäre einem mundschutz gewesen
ganz aspekt
ich werde ich mal drei meter hoch
gekommen das ist tatsächlich auch wieder
mein liebesleben in den aktuell
ich wünsche uns nämlich fest
[Musik]
ihr wisst bescheid
[Applaus]
[Musik]
irgendwie habe ich gehofft dass er ins
wasser fällt von da kommt wieder meine
schadenfreude raus das sind die kleinen
dinge im leben die einen glücklich
machen
für mich ist das zum beispiel am
schönsten wenn ich bin wieder wald nicht
das war schon der zweite clip von euch
heute
das niveau das ist das ist nicht mehr
zugreifen
das kriegst auf jeden fall den preis für
den besten freund des jahres dienstag
haase für die gefahr groß ist dass ich
will nichts sagen meine lieben freunde
habe ich habe auch eine kleine schwester
und bei uns was damals genau so von
daher könnte eigentlich könnte könnte
keiner von euch mit harmonika spielen
ich nicht
[Applaus]
[Gelächter]
was habe ich mir hier gerade angeguckt
das frage ich mich grundsätzlich bei
jedem
hundertprozentig
früher gewesen
oder vielleicht auch jetzt immer noch
[Musik]
warum machst du tech talks und malz
nicht beruflich
[Musik]
hey jungs oder eure tik tok sind wir nur
halb so viel lernen den tip top news
episoden
also zieht immer mehr zusammen
ein bisschen sex erst durch den bernern
deinen kopf schmeißen alexa ja spieletag
und nie von aha
[Musik]
ich kannte und mir nicht in deiner
medien alexa aus china junge alexa
spieltag monika haben
hier sind titel basierend am alexa spiel
doch einfach take on me dann wenn ich
jetzt noch mal so kündigen
er hat extrem rechts ich wusste ich dass
es in amerika auch sonst ist der lehrer
gibt einfach so sagen canyon in
deutschland immer wenn ich gefragt habe
kann ich mir auftritte geht ich weiß
nicht ob du das kannst der mitmenschen
nicht sind ziemlich abstoßend
rostock
ja und an der stelle wo heute die so
nötig sei jetzt auch beenden meine
lieben freunde wenn es euch gefallen ist
dann das gerne einen daumen hoch und dem
video erfolg mehr auf tik tok und
instagram ich heiße laserdruckern
schreibt mir eurem tik tok namen unten
in die kommentare dann kommt ihr
eventuell in die nächste episode tik tok
user nächste woche dienstag und ihr
findet jetzt hier ein smiley
eingeblendet wenn ihr da draufsteht
könnte ihm einen kanal kostenlos
abonniert ist kostenlos und da passt
keine videos mehr wie das hier gerade
beispielsweise also klickt auf den
smiley wenn ihr noch kein teil der look
so sad und hier findet ihr ein anderes
video verlinkt mega cool da es sich
amerikanische süßigkeiten es war echt
lecker
also klickt dampf drauf